Aspen and I thought well why not go and
see that the chess Hustlers there so
Aspen sat down and played against one of
the older guys and Aspen is not a bad
player but he got completely crushed in
that game
and uh
I needed to uh to restore the honor of
the Norwegians there in Washington
Square Park that moment you know I don't
know who it was so I would just play
I tried to win but when I see him make a
move you know he's uh already I know he
is like you know very strong person
even like maybe 10 move you know he
checked me
he came you know with the movie star you
know I forget her name they come to me
and say do you know who you're playing
but I didn't know what I was playing
with him who he was but I know that he
was a good player played it played a
couple games didn't play too badly but I
beat him quite Handler